is a very, very, very delicate
instrument It's a delicate
instrument. What do I mean by
that? I want you to look at the
Quran as a map. It's a map.
It's the technology you are
using to reach Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. and the only way
that you can make head or tails
of that map is if your heart is
pure. Describe the Quran as
guidance guidance for the
people who are pious. Those who
revere Allah. Those who fear
Allah, Those who abstain from
the prohibitions of Allah. And
those who follow through with
the commandments of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Those who
are vanguards and stand at the
boundaries of Allah Subhanahu
wa ta'ala and do not cross
them. This is what opens the
heart. The heart is a delicate
instrument. The heart, I'm not
speaking about your heart
that's beating in your chest.
The location of the heart as
referred to in the Quran is in
the chest. Just our soul
is in our body. How is our
soul? We don't know. How is our
proverbial heart? We don't
know. but it has a connection
to our brain and our physical
heart. People ask questions
sometimes because Allah said
it is not really the eyes that
are true blind. Blindness is
not blindness of the eyes but
blindness is truly blindness of
the heart. The hearts which are
located in the chest of men.
That is what Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala said. So, the heart is
in the chest. That is where it
is located. Now, he is speaking
about the heart which is part
of the soul. It resides in the
heart that is in the chest. It
resides and has connection with
our minds and our brains.
That's how we take in
information and the heart is
what? Calculates that
information and makes decisions
for us. That's how we make our
decisions. And so I want you to
look at the Quran as a map. It
is the way that you are going
to navigate your way to Allah
That is what the the Quran is.
It's a guide Allah said at the
very beginning of the Quran
Hudan.
That's what the that's what the
Quran is. It's guidance. It
guides you a map. But that
map can't be read properly
unless you have a compass.
Unless you know which direction
you're going, you can't make
head or tails of this map. It
could be upside down, it could
be sideways, you don't know.
Until you are able know which
way is north and able to infer
from that the rest of the
directions, you will not be
able to use the map and that is
why Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
said that the Quran Shahid. He
said about the Quran that it is
for those who listen with
focus, listen, focus,
listening. They're not just
hearing the Quran. They're
listening to it. While their
soul their entire aura is
present. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala also says that the Quran
is for those who have a heart.
It's for those who have a
heart. What does that mean?
They have this delicate
instrument by which it is pure.
They keep it clean. right? They
keep their heart clean as clean
as possible. So that when they
go to read the Quran, they will
understand what it is really
intended to be understood as.
The Quran is perfectly
ambiguous. It's general enough
to include all of us but
specific enough to guide
everyone of us to Allah. And
it's been that way for fifteen
hundred years. A book that can
guide you and I all the way
here in Chicago, across the
world, across fifteen hundred
years. How can this apply to
us. How? We have different
thoughts, different
backgrounds, different
different ways, different
customs, different way of
looking at the world. Our world
is different, right? Yet this
Quran can still apply to us.
This Quran still guides us. And
so it's general enough to be
able to include all times and
places and people. And it's
specific enough to guide you
specific to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. That's given that your
heart is pure. The pure your
heart, the more you will be
given from the understanding of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. If
no mentions in his book Al
Fawaed. He says that the heart
of the human being is the
throne of Allah. Subhanahu wa
ta'ala. That's an interesting
comparison, isn't it? How is
the Quran? How is the heart of
the human being similar to the
throne of Allah? He said, just
as the throne of Allah is the
greatest of creations and had
to be the purest for Allah to
rise above it. Just that,
the heart has to be absolutely
pure for Allah's names and
attributes and wisdom and
knowledge to rise above it. In
order for your heart to be
penetrated and for the Quran
and Sunnah to reside in it, it
has to be clean. It can be
filthy. and the Quran. Filth
and purity cannot be in the
same place. Just light and
and darkness can't be in the
same place. Just it can't
be daytime and night time at
the same time. Just black
and white can't be in the same
place. There's stark opposites.
And so the filth of a Shaitan
has to be removed. And now I'm
going to give you a parable. An
example of the heart. And I
want you to take this and
contemplate it. Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala taught us how to seek
refuge from a Shaitan. And in
the closing chapter of the
Quran. Look how Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala organized the Quran.
It's truly amazing isn't it? It
begins with
him. You're starting a journey.
Right? and at the very end the
very end of the book, what does
it leave us with?
[Silence]
our recitation of the Quran.
Look at the organization You
look at the organization of the
Quran, it is mind blowing. It
is, it is above and beyond what
a human being could ever
organize, could ever perfect,
to intrude, into the darkest
corners of the human heart, and
enlighten them. And so, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala begins the
Quran with what? Alhamdulillah
and then he goes on to mention
the straight path. Then he goes
on to mention what that path
is. He mentions the Quran. That
is the path of Allah. And then
he mentions the people of that
path. And those who are on it.
And to whom the Quran will be
of consequence. Right? And we
go through this journey when we
read the Quran. Until we leave,
we are left with the final
verses of the Quran. What are
the final verses of the Quran?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
teaches us and leaves us after
this long journey. Mentioning
twenty-five different prophets.
The story of Musa Alaihi Salam,
the story of Yusuf. We go
through the journey of the of
Ibrahim Alaihi Salam. We are
with them. As Ibrahim makes
with his wife Sarah. When they
leave their town and he says to
his wife, there is noone on
this earth. Today, a believer
except for me and you. We're
the only two. That's what
Ibrahim said and Muslim to his
wife. And then believed. And he
was appointed as a prophet as
well. We go through the journey
of Lut. We go through the
journey of we go into the belly
of a whale We go through all of
the beauty and the splendor of
the heavens and the earth, the
constellations. He takes us
through all this journey and
then at the very end, he leaves
us with what does he say? Say,
I see refuge in the lord of the
people Melecanes, the king of
the people. The only one true
deity worthy of worship Of the
people.
I seek refuge and he from the
evil. Of
Hanes.
We want to take a moment
here to understand what is
is a description of a Shaitan,
correct? That's his
description. Allah describes
him as two things. He says,
West West, Hanness, he says the
continuous, unremitant,
whisperer, of evil, and the one
who is in constant retreat.
That's his description. So, to
sum up everything that we know
about a Shaitan and his
relationship with the human
being is that he is whispering
and retreating. That is what he
is constantly doing. He's
either doing one of those two
things. Now, the scholars of
Tefsia, they tell us. Why is it
that Why is it that He was
described as the whisperer in
constant retreat. They say, for
two reasons, number one, he is
a retreats when people obey
him. And he retreats when
people obey Allah. What does
that mean? Meaning that he will
whisper to the person to do
evil. He whispers and whispers
and whispers. Until the person
does it. As soon a person does
it, he retreats. He washes his
hands of him. He says, anybody
will mink. He says to him, I'm
innocent of you. That was your
choice, not mine. I have
nothing to do with that. So, he
leaves you in the air. He
leaves you in the wind. You
obey him and what is your
reward Your leader leaves you.
When you're in the midst of
chaos, when he turns your life
to slush, and makes your life a
misery, then, he will say to
you, I have nothing to do with
that. That was your choice. I
merely encouraged you and you
obeyed me. Allah promised you a
true promise and I promised you
but I have defied my promise.
I, I hereby denounce everything
that you all did. That's what
he will say on the day of
resurrection to his followers.
His most devoted followers on
the day of resurrection as the
flames of hell blaze. He will
talk to them and he will say,
Allah promised you a true
promise. And I also promised
you But I went back on my
promise. So do not blame me.
Blame yourselves. I have no
control over you nor you
control over me. I have hereby
denounced everything that you
all have done. And I am
innocent of it. That's what a
Shaitan does.
The
He continues to say to the
human being, disbelieve and
then when the man is on his
deathbed, he says and he is
dead, he is dying, the angels
of death are removing his soul,
Shaitan comes and whispers one
last whisper, hey, this is not
my fault. This is your fault.
Count me out. As a one last
goodbye. This is a Shaytan. The
second reason he is referred to
as the whisperer who is in
constant retreat is because
when a person obeys a law, and
mentions a law and remembers
Allah and seeks Allah and put
his hands to the heavens,
stretches his hands out to the,
to the heavens, seeking a law,
opens his heart to Allah, a
Shaitan runs and he is in
retreat from that. When you say
he retreats. But he'll come
back. Some people they say they
come and they ask questions.
They say man I have these
whispers. These whispers of
evil and they won't stop. And
they say how do I make them
stop? What's the answer to
that? It will never stop. You
can't make them stop. Nobody
can. It was only the prophet
Muhammad who was granted that.
He said to Aisha, every single
person has a Shaitan that is
appointed to him from the day
he is born. From the moment he
comes out of his mother's womb,
a Shaitan is there. And that
will be his designated demon
for the rest of his life. In
Knows you, he studies you in
and out. He comes to you in
your dreams. He watches you as
you sleep. He's with you when
you eat. He walks in your home
if you do not remember Allah.
He eats your food if you do not
remember Allah. He is with you
with your spouse if you do not
remember Allah. This is what
the prophet tells us. And so,
when a person says
he retreats. He retreats. It's
mentioned in Muslim that when
the is called, he plugs his
ears and flees. He runs. He
can't stand to hear it. Because
of the guilt he carries.
Because of the fear of Allah
that he has. But because of his
arrogance, he will always be
destined in hell bound. And so,
How do we get the whispers to
stop? They will never stop. You
learn mental toughness. You
learn how to ignore those
whispers. And not only that,
but Allah has not just left us
with a demon. There's glad
tidings. In hadith the prophet
said,
He says that a Shaitan has
[Silence]
Matter of fact, some scholars
say that we have two angels and
one demon. What does that mean?
That means that the angels that
are on our right and left-hand
side, the one that writes the
good deeds and the one that
writes the bad, then They don't
just sit there idle and write
what you do They counter the
whispers of a Shaitan. They
interact with you. So, that
angel that writes your good
deeds, he's constantly
encouraging you to do the good
deed. He's not just sitting
there idle. He's there waiting,
encouraging you. Do this deed.
Do that deed so I can write it.
Make this, make what I write
plentiful. and the one on the
left who writes the bad deeds
will continue to deter you from
the bad deed until you force
him to write it. but even when
you force him to write it, it's
mentioned that Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala says to him, wait.
Don't write it yet. Give him a
few hours, maybe he'll repent.
Maybe he'll seek my forgiveness
and you won't need to write it
at all. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala is the most loyal. He's
there for you. The odds are
stacked in your favor. are
seven gates to hell and how
many gates to paradise Eight
that means what? That means
that it is easier to get into
paradise than it is to hell.
That means that it is more
likely to get into paradise
than it is to get into hell.
But some people refuse but to
go to hell. And so I will give
you an example of a Shaitan.
and I want you to listen to
this example with your heart.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala uses
three terms in the Quran to
refer to the heart. He uses a
the chest He uses the heart and
he uses the heart, the
passionate heart, okay? Now, in
Allah said, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala said that
[Silence]
I'll give you the example that
has given.
It's
mentioned that the heart
is a palace. The heart is
a palace. It's your
palace. It's a temple. It's a
masjid. It's a place where good
or evil can reside. You can
make it into a temple of Allah,
a a masjid of Allah, a place of
worship, of a law, or you can
make it into a squatting.
Grounds for evil and filth.
an abandoned crack house,
a building that has been
neglected, and only bagavans,
and the wicked visit this
filthy place. Only those who
are accustomed to filth will
come into this place. You start
out with a pure heart. And
around this heart, there is
offense, a wall.
and that wall is your chest
okay? As Shaitan, when he
starts with you, he is on the
outside of this wall. He's not
inside What does he do? He
throws trash over the wall into
your into your courtyard into
your chest. He whispers into
the chest of men, right? Not
the hearts. That's not what he
said. And so, imagine a
Shaitan, around the walls of
this palace, and your your
palace, your masjid, your
temple, your heart is in the
center. There is an expansive
courtyard and there are gates
and a Shaitan is on the
outside. He can't get in. But
what does he do? He starts to
throw trash and rubbish over
the wall into the into the
courtyard. Now if you allow
that to continue, what will
happen? courtyard will become a
place of filth, correct? The
filth now is approaching the
heart. And so if you continue
to allow him to do that, you
will eventually let him into
the courtyard. But if you
continue to clean out
everything he throws in, you
throw it back over. You stand
at the courtyard. You don't
stay inside the house, the
palace. You don't wait in
there. You have a boundary. So
you stay in the courtyard and
you stay on top of it.
The prophet said, follow up a
bad deed with a good one and it
will erase it That's what he
said. And so every time he
throws over a piece of trash,
you pick it up and throw it
back at him. And you keep your
courtyard clean all the time,
every day. You're vigilant. But
if you allow him to trash out
your courtyard, he'll
eventually come inside and sit
in the courtyard. Now, he's
throwing trash at the gates of
your palace. And if you don't
clean that out, he'll come and
sit at the door of the palace
And now he'll start throwing
trashware inside the palace.
Every time the heart opens, he
throws trash in. Every time the
door opens, he throws trash in.
People ask, why is music haram?
Because music opens the heart
whether you it or not.
It's tunes cause your heart to
become open immediately. And if
a Shaitan is sitting right
there at the door, he'll start
to throw trash and garbage
inside of the palace. after he
gets the palace Grand Sachs, he
will go inside and he'll sit
inside the palace. Now, try to
get him out. You are now going
to climb and crawl on your
belly to try to get him out of
your heart. He's gotten inside
now. Now, you've made it his
palace. And so he will invite
all of his demon friends inside
of there. And they will all
trash and ransack your heart
and leave it a hollow hole. As
hollow as a as as hollow as as
as a shadow in a memory. Black,
dark, the only thing that will
open the gates of that heart is
when a Shaitan says, yeah, you
can let this one in. And at
that point, you belong to him.
You've made your choice
How do we counter this? We
counter this by what?
Continuing to be vigilant and
not allowing a Shaitan into our
chest and into our courtyards.
Into our proverbial hearts. We
don't let that happen. Every
time he throws over a piece of
trash, we throw it back over at
him. And we throw a good deed.
We throw over Allah's
remembrance And he runs And he
comes back. And he starts
throwing trash in there again.
And you throw it back at him.
And you continue this process
until you draw your last breath
and think your final thoughts.
That is how it works. The
whispers will never stop.
They'll never go away. They
might cease for a moment. You
might say and get temporary
relief but that's your
struggle. He'll always be
there. He was there the day you
were born. Before you were
even, before you were even able
to comprehend good and evil. He
was there from the day you were
born and he looked at you as a
candidate. A candidate for
what? For the blazing hellfire
of Allah. Subhan Allah. And so,
We counter this as the prophet
told us. There's a narration on
the authority of a couple of
the companions
also
collected by the that the
prophet said,
the
[Silence]
Even if you're in the dark, say
to yourself, the one who
created darkness is the one who
is watching me right now.
And if you happen to make a
mistake, which is inevitable,
you will. He says, follow up
every mistake you make with a
good deed and it will erase it.
You make a mistake, you say a
stuff for Allah and then you go
out of your way to do a good
deed. To erase that. He says,
and have the best of character
with other people. Observe the
best of character with other
people. Those are the three
things he tells us to fortify
us from a Shaitan. So, this is
the heart. It's a compass. It's
a very delicate instrument. You
have to be very vigilant of it.
Let me ask you a question. If
you were in the desert and you
had a map that told you exactly
how to get out of that mess.
And you had a compass which was
the only instrument you have to
make heads or tails of that
map. Would you just neglect the
compass? Would you just throw
it around? Leave it wherever.
Let anybody touch it. Let it
fall on the ground. Maybe break
it. Let the water leak out of
it. Would you do that? No. Is
that how you would treat your
compass? If you knew that this
was your lifeline? Of course
not. If you knew that this was
your lifeline, it would be the
most protected thing that you
have. Two things you would
protect the most. In that
situation. What are those two
things? The compass and the
map. Those you would always
check to make sure you have
them. Every time you walk,
you're nervous, you're
checking. Do I have them with
me. And this is what is called
reflection. You're reflecting
on your heart
Who said
he said judge yourself before
you are judged by Allah. and
weigh yourselves before you are
weighed on the scales of Allah
on the day of resurrection.
That's called reflection. You
reflect on what you're doing.
You're constantly checking your
heart Is it working right? Or
is it getting filthy? Is it
starting to become inaccurate?
Because the more you mistreat
your heart, the more you let
others handle it. The more you,
toss it around, and let anybody
use it. The more you give it to
others and open it for everyone
to see, the more inaccurate it
will become until you will read
the Quran thinking you are
guided but in fact, you are
reading it upside down. The
Quran is ambiguous in many
things. People who are
murderers, find justification
for their murder in the Quran.
and people who stand around in
the Masjid and beat drums and
clap and dance and run around,
they find justification for
that wear in the Quran.
Correct? and people who don't
pray find justification for
that in the Quran. You know
why? Because their heart is
black and they see the Quran
only what they want to see of
it. They only see what they
want. and I will leave you with
this narration which so
beautifully sums up the way
that the, the way that the
heart is. Allah, the prophet
said, in to our
the
[Silence]
is braided. It's just one
little thing that is braided
into another. One at a time
He said,
every time
this heart accepts
every time one of this heart
rejects this, a white.will be
placed on his heart and that
white.will grow. And every time
he accepts the fitna and he
falls into haram and he is
fooled by the illusion, it will
place a black.on his heart and
it will grow. Until hearts
become one of two He said,
either a heart that is white
and as strong as rock. no fitna
will ever be able to penetrate
that heart as long as the
heavens and earth are in
existence. And the other is a
black heart. an upside
down vessel. Imagine yourself
taking a cup, turning it upside
down, and trying to get a glass
of water. It's upside down. It
will never fill up. He said
this heart will never
acknowledge good nor will it
ever recognize evil for what it
is except for what his own
desires and fancies accept.
That is your journey through
this world And that is the
relationship of your heart to
the Quran. That is enough for
tonight. We will listen to the
Adan.